ce nouveau naufrage en méditerranée
mercredi 366 personnes âgées de 15 à 48
ans ont été secourus par les marines
tunisienne et libyenne
dix sept personnes ont trouvé la mort
selon les autorités tunisiennes une
enquête a été ouverte pour connaître les
circonstances exactes du naufrage
les précisions de notre correspondant au
maghreb bassin chebbi un nouveau
sauvetage en mer pour la marine
tunisienne qui assiste impuissante à l'
exode de populations venues d'asie et
d'afrique subsaharienne a contrainte de
passer par les côtes tunisiennes et
libyennes pour rejoindre l'europe
mercredi près de trois cent soixante six
migrants ont été secourus au large des
côtes tunisiennes
dix sept personnes y ont laissé la vie
selon le chef du croissant-rouge dans le
gouvernorat de médenine ses 366 migrants
étaient principalement originaires du
bangladesh du maroc ou encore de
l'egypte selon nos informations ces
migrants sont décédés des suites de
suffocation dus à la fumée du moteur du
bateau après un problème survenu en
pleine mer pour le directeur exécutif du
forum tunisien des droits économiques et
sociaux tant que des solutions ne seront
pas trouvé entre l'union européenne et
les pays du sud
les tentatives de migration illégale
continueront de prendre de l'ampleur
on va compter toujours le nombre des
disparus on va compter toujours le
nombre des morts dans le bassin permien
parce qu'il n'ya pas des approches
ceux qui cherchent une solution durable
ni sur le plan législatif vous faut pas
oublier l'italie jusqu'aujourd'hui elle
criminalise le sauvetage en mer
l'union européenne finance les la garde
maritime la tunisienne ou bien
européenne aussi avec le système de
frontex pour le décompte des migrations
l'objectif s'il était contraint
migration et non pas à sauver des êtres
humains
je crois que le message est clair la
lutte au togo mais quand cette migration
ne pas si jamais par la solution
sécuritaire faut des solutions durables
sont des solutions dignes et des
solutions qui respectent les droits
humains
je crois que c'est important de se
lancer dans un dialogue
mais d'etarras mien depuis le début de
l'année la tunisie a secouru et
accueilli plus d'un millier de migrants
parti de libye dont les embarcations
avait fait naufrage ce sont pas moins de
onze mille départs par la mer depuis la
libye soit 73 % de plus qu'à la même
période l'an passé en raison notamment
des crises politiques économiques et
sociales dans la région